with dignity and respect
committed to free speech in some sense
be entertaining
straight talking and direct we may have
to take each other and you provoking
provocative and controversial hello and
welcome to a very special festive
edition of the pledge coming up we've
got plenty of Christmas cheer for you as
well as a sprinkling of traditional
family squabbles and sugar fueled debate
but first in keeping with Yuletide
spirit we've all taken part in a secret
Center to treat each other to a truly
meaningful gift
so Greg here you go Merry Christmas I
wonder if you can work out the shake
wanted to give Carol one yes thank you
done you know what this is whoever's
wrap these is got mental okay I'll get
into them no don't tell me what it is
cheese this yeah here we go here we go
oh I know what is it this is masking
tape
[Laughter]
have more columns than the puffin and
I'm gonna try and make sure I can just
like angel in my life let's get there
really quickly here we go move on what's
it what does it say you will see at the
same time Christmas Day Harold sees it
loud for all to hear a for thinks we
might have taken things a bit too far
Rachel wants to scrap all that Christmas
waste I pick my person of the year and
Greg claims yes it is Greg claims to be
psychic again but just before we start I
lead to thee to let you know panel that
this week is officially a brexit free
zone anyone called uttering the B word
will be expected to contribute
generously to this brexit the last word
you'll hear last time you'll hear that
word
swear jar you have been warned but first
over to our very own Christmas Carol
so it's Christmas and you're humming all
your favorite seasonal tunes and one of
them is that timeless forties classic
let's have a listen I really can't
[Music]
I've got to go for people he'll be
living in a cave for the whole of their
lives that was baby it's cold outside
only we can't sing it anymore and some
radio stations they've already banded
because apparently it conjures up images
of sexual harassment and drugging drinks
only it doesn't well only the
sex-obsessed minds of the terminally
offended me tOA's who had they bothered
to listen to or read about the song
would know it had nothing to do with sex
or rape or a man playing a woman was
drink it was written by Broadway
composer Frank Loesser for him and his
wife Ling to sinner parties to tell
people it was time to go home and why is
this sweet little song being banned when
many top 40 songs objectify women and
routinely glorify guns fighting drugs
and sex I don't hear me - calling for a
ban on those I'm sorry but you can't put
baby and a cultural corner for the rest
of time just because a bunch of
oversensitive easily offended PC zealots
have claimed it's rapey when it's a
million miles from that Carol I feel I
can't sit here dressed like this you
know what Carol why should Christmas be
a license to do things that the rest of
the year we think are out of step with
the time well what I should create
anyway tell me why this song is rape
your hands today first of all first of
all it's not been fans Carol that's
that's an American no stations have
chosen dinner to play it some radio
stations totally thought police are
gonna come along and put you in
handcuffs if you decide to Hamid along
as you just did I will explain why and
actually I have to say on my list of
things that I feel I need to fight for
with my energy
maybe not my top ten but there are
people who feel that it's problematic
and I respect their opinion and one of
them is a music journalist called
Stephen Guzman and this is what he says
a woman has stopped by to visit a man
and he connived to keep her from leaving
my answer is no she states but he pulls
on the charm
it's up
to your knees out there his seductions
become increasingly smarmy and
eventually sinister at one point she
claims say what's in this drink it's he
being generous with the alcohol or has
he slipped her something stronger it's
all too clear that he's a predator and
she's hammerhead what's he called
Stephen okay how do you actually read
the words of that song
what do you see it's about if he really
wants to get out red what did she get
outraged about is the double standards
in regards to sex because what she is
saying in that song I really want to
stay
she's plying herself with drinks she
said I want half a drink more
give me another cigarette she doesn't
want to go home convention of the time
she knows Chuck she says in the song she
says my mother will start to worry my
father will be pacing the floor and my
sister will be suspicious my brother
will be it there at the door yeah my
husband won't be too happy as well but
they cut that line out I think it's
alright for him to stay out but it's not
alright for her to stay so it's not
about a man trying to get nothingness
who agree with you Carol and say that
this is a song about female agency in a
patriarchal world the principle here is
this is a song that was written in what
the 13 90 forties and we can't go back
and music and we can't censor it in the
light today yes completely crackers
Morris as far as I'm concerned and known
and look at fairy tale of New York which
people are also saying should be bad
eyes and cut because it's got offensive
language in it and said let's have a
wait and let's agree it does I don't
find it an evident but it's the greatest
Christmas song ever written this Shane
MacGowan
[Music]
I
the truck time
[Music]
the lyrics are spying chilling their
brilliant lyrics they do contain trigger
warning everybody words two words [ __ ]
and [ __ ] and they when they're played
on the radio now I think they sometimes
they're but Shane MacGowan as Bob Geldof
said when criticized for the lyrics of
dem they know it's Christmas quite
rightly he did say it's not a political
treatise it's a song I have no idea but
anyway the arty broadcaster Ian
McDermott I think he says there's enough
vitriol out there without gay people
having to feel uncomfortable so people
that aren't affected by an insult can
tap their toe the fact is this song is a
classic isn't strong enough defense so
not at least censored if the song was
released now with that word fairytale of
New York was written in I don't know the
90s what Shane McGavin also said was it
sit in a drunk tank yes where the people
have been shut out as a capitalist magic
circle are there the losers the scumbags
the drugs that's where they're spending
Christmas and he says the woman who's
saying this is not supposed to be a nice
or a wholesome woman she's that she's a
woman of a certain time of a certain
generation who was down in desperate so
he wanted it to be authentic and it's a
brilliant so there are some Christmas
songs here listen to this one
[Music]
if I go to one more supermarket and
knotty hold on there is singing I'm
gonna go probably can't believe how much
he makes every Christmas I remember
listening to do they know it's Christmas
as a little girl mother thinking why are
these people talking about a whole
continent like they're left out because
it doesn't snow at Christmas I mean it's
in a context where people are so
genuinely ignorant I haven't even got
involved you know you said it was
sinister a baby it's I was a music
journalist right I did the bizarre
column and the Sun for about three years
I'm telling you there's nothing man with
that song there's nothing male with the
Pope song they are lyrics there's
nothing you cannot view 1944 songs
through 2018 or 2019 soon bosses don't
you think it's good to have a
conversation I'm not talking about
censorship later songs are important
cultural forces and they normalize ideas
into our culture yeah rape and misogyny
[Applause]
that we're now starting is why is that
white Savior narratives in Africa have
been very normalized for a long time I'm
very happy that now when people here do
they know it's Christmas they start to
mention it this is a bank I know those
things that you just said this is about
cavitation with a woman it's about
rotation and she knows she has to get
him and she knows if she does as it
should be judged by society it's so she
has to go I've made the mistake of
writing novels and I remember sometimes
my very few readers would write to me
and say you made a mistake in that novel
this doesn't it couldn't have happened
these are creative artifacts they're not
purporting to be Factory factually
correct one of the key says he rivers
literature and culture give us is that
we can discuss
basically analyzed them and it makes us
and smart you can't sanitize